i'm going to give my give advice to  anybody out there that's been going  through this crazy madness from the from  the legal side the non-legal side to the  legal side  keep pushing  don't ever [ __ ] give up on your  passion and  especially if you love the plant  fight all the way baby because if you're  a good [ __ ] person  right you do good you treat people good  good shit's gonna happen to you bro of  course it's just the way the world is  homie  god is good and if you're a [ __ ] good  person and you grind and you love this  [ __ ] plant stick with it no matter  how many times you get shot down  turned down  [ __ ] you  keep [ __ ] pushing  you know what i mean keep [ __ ]  pushing message of the show man keep  pushing it's all you could do closed  everything well truly truly does